I'm this much drunk to answer your
question so today we are giving advice
I'm drunk I've had a lot of pink wine I
am drinking champagne and I am tipsy
with my friends I give a lot of advice
with random strangers I give a lot of
advice I'm drinking a white zinfandel
and I'm good that glass looks empty sure
is you look like a hard day I have a few
things that have been on my mind and I'm
looking for some sound advice you know
I'm drunk right I do now you know me
really well you know how like I'm a
perfectionist to a tee I feel like I'm
like stuck at this place I work so hard
on things like super super hard for a
long time and then at the end of the day
I'm not like that I don't even feel
better about in the end so I know your
hair looks so pretty in this light yeah
it's a pretty color okay anyways
everybody feels like they're not good
enough especially when you see people
doing things around you that are amazing
at a no reality all of us are really
doing that anyway and we just need to
give ourselves the credit for it start
there and then watch yourself fly maybe
some wine yeah maybe that'll help it's
hot in here this is a problem I've had
my entire life I have such an issue with
telling people that I have feelings for
that I have feelings for them what I
can't do it
I mean we've you in a role play sure
okay since dammit I really value our
friendship first and foremost however I
just want to say moving forward this is
how I feel so I want that dick
shouldn't I be me and you be the person
cuz like don't I need to practices I
- also want that dick wait where are we
are you I don't know
are you mu are you mean I'm very very
lost right I got this text for my best
friend Evan yeah I was asking her she
wanted to hang out this weekend and she
literally just responded with a K and I
don't I feel like our relationship is
now on the rocks because you know Devon
yeah really well but if she ever texted
you just okay no and I don't mean that
that means anything about like our
ranking of like friendship with Devon
like I'm not saying that you're just
getting a K after like hours of being
ignored means that you're less than mean
when you say it like that my instinct
would be to be a little worried really
no you're being really blase about this
yeah and this is like my best friendship
Cheers
the timing of this is kind of perfect I
recently fired my therapist should I see
other therapists or is this enough oh no
it's not an attic no no so I feel like
finding a therapist is like dating
personally and it's like you never know
if it's going to work out the first time
or you kind of have to see multiple
people you know to see you like what's
gonna vibe with you I feel like you
should do that
you're just gotta get myself back out
there yeah whether you are the best
whatever that means
the best ever or in like your worst like
you still need to talk and process stuff
I do yeah we all do just remember that
though that like you're important and
you deserve that I haven't been told
that in a while or you can just uh fill
me in pencil me in every Tuesday and
just give me a 40 bucks back here right
about here I really want to get in
better shape to work out more to eat
better that's the big one is eating
better but I constantly eat fast food
fast food we talk about I'm a real [ __ ]
for fast food talk to me talk to me give
my goodness
jack-in-the-box McDonald's Taco Bell I
just need a lot of fast food all the
major chains burp you alright it's okay
are there any healthier options at these
fast-food establishments
there's salads there's grilled chicken
sandwiches I do you like grilled chicken
yeah well that's the first step in
getting healthy doesn't like the rock
Dwayne Johnson eat like seven pounds of
grilled chicken no it's cod heat Scott
it day will get there we're gonna work
our way up to that I've had this friend
that I've been like pretty much best
friends with my whole life but lately
you know his beauty he's gone a bit off
like the political deep a make some very
strange tweets that kind of stuff how do
I sort of end this relationship that
I've had for a while now who and I think
you just have to be kind of
straightforward I think that's something
you have to like really you're just
gonna have to accept that there's gonna
be a little confrontation right to find
out yeah I think that was actually very
helpful I think I can take this maybe
the alcohol helped but you're always
blunt anyways yeah I think a drunk or
sober my advice giving ability is a
I think this personally is how therapy
should be done you come up to a little
desk and you drink some champagne and
we're just sitting here chat and talking
I didn't great I was there with them you
know I'm not here to judge and I'm gonna
build you up and I'm gonna give you some
of this pink wine because it helps
[Music]